hey friends I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel with today I wanted to talk
about half-life Alex and everything that
I know about this game because I did
know about the game for it was announced
I actually mentioned it in a YouTube
video on this channel in July 2016
saying it was going to be a VR game and
even in the comments back then nobody
believed me but we'll we'll get to that
I know some more stuff I thought now
would be the time to share so in case
you've been living under a rock valve
software tweeted on November 18th we're
excited to unveil half-life Alex our
flagship VR game this Thursday at 10
p.m. 10 a.m. Pacific time I quote
tweeted that said oh wow cool and posted
this clip on a hug in twenty three said
how many months do you think until
half-life 3 drops no drug that game is
in development like this is the thing
that I can't even really meet because
nobody would ever believe me but it
isn't it's via ok good day some people
did respond to that being like damn did
she just out of nowhere leak half-life 3
but mostly people assumed I was joking
even though I was being completely
serious I have known about this since
late last year I thought it was either
going to come out late this year or
early next year it looks like it is
actually much 2020 one thing that I can
tell you before we delve into some more
specifics is that I was told this is
half-life 3 but the one thing that I
will say that I think people who are
reacting to this are off base about is
disappointment that it's a VR game I'm
sure if I just open the comments on IGN
here this is not half-life 3 this is
half-life take this until three comes
out there's gotta be one here that I'm
looking for
yeah VR it's all about yeah everyone is
complaining about this exact thing
they're making one they're making a VR
game and everyone is responding to that
with negativity people are disappointed
that they aren't making a PC exclusive
and I think that is the most misguided
you could be about this game I do have
to be cautious of embargoes here but I'm
gonna tell you something
I'll just be a secret the way the video
games are out right now is going to
change dramatically in the next few
years I know that I've seen some of them
you cannot fathom how much video games
are going to change soon and a really
good way to paint this picture is I had
a conversation with Ken Levine and he
said that for anyone doesn't know that's
the creator of Bioshock he said that he
thinks that even Bioshock was just
half-life rescanned basically the idea
is that every generally first-person
shooter that has come out has just been
half-life reskin they all tend to follow
the same structure they tend to follow
the same level design they follow the
same narrative you have the same
experience play at a player which means
the video games are hugely limited they
are not reaching their full potential
because the full potential of video
games right now is unfathomable I
promise this relates to half-life Alex I
promise just bear with me this is a lot
of concept I'm dumping on you right now
the things we can do with AI the things
we can do with programming and the tech
the things that we can literally do with
video games we haven't even scratched
the surface I think a lot of people who
are high up in game design or narrative
design specifically I'm sure there are
loads of people who love the weight
games made right now but I know there
are people who are high up in the games
industry who believe that basically
video games right now
just movies with little interactive bits
and because of how limitless the tech is
because you can basically program
anything you want to happen video games
aren't reaching their full potential so
I have seen some games that do this this
next level thing that video games should
do which is about making every
experience you have completely different
to someone else's and dying light too is
actually the first game to come out that
I think is actually on this concept and
it's crazy to me that nobody's really
realizing what they're doing but it's
probably because they don't have the
context of what this is going to mean
for the future of video games let me
pull up some dying light footage so I
don't know that we'll see it in this
clip but dying light 2 is a game from
Techland they make cool stuff I really
like dying light and one very special
thing about this game is
the city that you see right here will
change visually depending on what you do
in this story and oh I think this is an
exact example of what they what they
were talking about it will change
depending on what happens in the story
but that would be different for every
single person who plays it basically you
could maybe align with one faction a
little bit or align with another one a
little bit and that will change the way
the world around you looks it will
change the way different people treat
you it will change dialogue you hear it
will change interactions and I know that
there are some studios who are working
on changes that are so explicit that
players will never even hear the same
paragraph of dialogue they've had
writers write in a way and voice actors
record in a way that you could splice
sentences together from completely
different places in the script that
would still make sense for any given
player based on what they do and what
order they did it in and what choices
they made and who they aligned with and
whatever else and this is basically what
I think the future of video games is I'm
sure this sounds crazy and preachy right
now come back here in 10 years and I'm
sure you will see what I'm talking about
because right now I know this premise is
very hard for devs to make I know it is
very difficult for them to execute but
the idea is that the future of video
games are things that aren't just
cutscenes with combat in between is that
they are fully about you experiencing
something completely different to
anything you could experience you're not
just watching something you are
experiencing something different to what
everyone else is experiencing different
to the next time you play through the
thing and to do that it means they have
to get rid of some biggest set pieces it
means sometimes they have to get rid of
the way cutscenes walk something like
the song bud crashing through in
BioShock Infinite might not be possible
because they can't have scripted
sequences like that because that is
again more like a video game being a
movie less like a video game reaching
the full potential of being a video game
okay
I've dumped that concept I'm concept
onto you pay attention to dying light
too I swear to God and more games that
are doing this will come out so back to
half-life I was told that this is what a
half-life Alex was basically planning to
do I don't know if they managed to pull
it
frankly because of the fact that it's
coming out early next year means I think
it probably isn't but there are
intentionally a lot of shots of the city
a few shots of this one city and I I
don't know like if this could be this
environment could be shifted depending
on what you've done but like the ship
looks very different here to how it
looks in other settings so I I don't
know if they managed to pull it off but
I know that was the plan even if they
didn't manage to do this grand video
game changing thing that I'm telling you
about the reason that half-life 3 or
half-life alex is a VR game is one you
should be excited about not one you
should be disappointed by valve have so
much money they basically just print
money they sit back and steam just
generates them revenue and sure it's
getting a little more competitive for
them now but for the most part wow do
they make a lot of money and have no
need to make video games or anyone who's
like why don't they make Lu and you look
for there was another portal why don't
they making a new team fortress I don't
know what accident that was there why
would they why would they do that if
they have no financial need to and they
always said with half-life and I was
told this too that they would not make a
new half-life unless they could do what
half-life 1 & 2 did which is change the
industry it is changed the way that
video games are made give new concepts
that people had never thought of before
and part of that goes back to this
concept I shared dying light has which I
believe I've heard some people talk to
you about like having like Lego blocks
like you would build a castle out of
Lego but everyone would have different
LEGO pieces and sure the castle would
end up being vaguely the same structure
but all of the pieces would be
completely different like that's how I
think they visualized this game design
structure if half luck didn't do that
they are at the very least going to
change via substantially they wouldn't
release it otherwise they are going to
make that killer app everyone's talking
about what people are disappointed this
game is coming to VR you should be
looking at it the opposite way around
this is the game that is the reason for
you to get VR it is the game that will
make other games in VR better you will
be
platform for VR this is the game we've
been waiting for for VI to kick off you
don't see that by seeing this trailer
and I get that but if it went the case
valve didn't want to make it if they
didn't feel like they were pushing and
improving the tech and starting a
foundation for something that that
actually creates that industry more or
less not that VR is an already honed by
millions of people but it's not you know
particularly hot when it comes to active
uses especially compared to other
platforms they wouldn't have made
half-life 3 if it weren't going to do
that so yeah if you're bummed that it's
in VR I think you're looking at it the
wrong way you should be thankful for
what this is going to do to the industry
not mad that it exists on hardware that
has otherwise got properties that you
might not be as interested in I hope
that makes sense so again I'm not
positive if based on this trailer if
they managed to put in the narrative
thing that I'm talking about but it's
still worth learning about are still
worth me telling you about still worth
paying attention to dying late to for
because I promise you it'll be a big
deal very soon but at the very least
this was made to change an industry and
I genuinely believe that they will do
that feel like this was a nerdy ass rant
sometimes I just get very passionate
about things and it's just I don't know
nuts watching people be disappointed
about this because I just don't think
they're realizing what valve is done I
hope that makes sense you have any more
questions for me let me know you know
the reason that I didn't make a video
just about this beforehand was because
frankly I didn't think anyone would
believe me I didn't think that people
would buy that what I was saying was
true that that half-life in VO was true
but no I didn't leak it back then
because it just it just wouldn't have
done anything I saw other websites try
to leak it for sure and it never gained
any traction I also just didn't have
enough to say and I feel like now it's
easier so thank you for watching I'll
see you guys next time